-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
♪♪
Big news today,
as Pfizer announced that
a low dose of its vaccine
is safe and effective
for kids ages 5 to 11.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's great news until you hear
a 6-year-old say,
"I want to do my own research
first."
Yeah, it's a version
of the Pfizer vaccine
that's much, much weaker,
so they're calling it
Johnson & Johnson.
I think it's --
They -- They --
That's right. The vaccine
is highly effective
for kids 5 to 11, meanwhile
4-year-olds are like,
"Yeah, don't mind us, we'll just
keep Clorox-wiping our Legos.
Okay?" Well...
Of course, a lot of kids
will get the vaccine,
while a small minority will
insist on taking pony dewormer.
[ Laughter ]
Because they're children.
-Yeah, they're children.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Not horse dewormer.
-That's correct.
-Ponies are smaller.
-Well, this is big news --
Pfizer decided to get
the word out with a new ad,
so...
I'm not sure they're sending
the right message, though.
Take a look at this.
-We here at Pfizer are dedicated
to improving the lives
of our customers, whether it's
through our popular vaccine,
soon to be available
to children,
or through the thing the rest of
you know us for -- Viagra.
Pfizer -- we helped you make
your kids,
now let us keep them safe.
-Interesting.
[ Laughs ]
Very interesting.
-Wow.
-Meanwhile, out in California,
I saw that some McDonald's
locations are now offering
free vaccines.
It's not every location,
so double check
before you let a clown
stab you with a needle.
Just -- I'm just saying.
Advice.
Yeah, that's right.
It took 66 years,
but there's finally something
healthy at McDonald's.
That's right, McDonald's
is offering vaccines.
Man, those guys will do anything
to avoid fixing
the ice-cream machines.
Anything. Just fix the thing!
Well, guys, this week,
world leaders are here
in New York City for the
United Nations General Assembly.
Yeah, all the world leaders are
here, and if you think your job
is stressful, imagine telling
Brazil's unvaccinated president
he's not allowed in Sbarro's.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile in New York City,
Mayor Bill de Blasio
addressed world leaders
and said,
"If you don't want
to be vaccinated,
don't bother coming."
New Yorkers
agreed with the mayor.
They were like, "Yeah, stay out!
And take de Blasio with you.
Take him, too."
[ Applause ]
Well, some more news here.
I saw that
former president Trump is trying
to find someone to replace
Mitch McConnell, even though
the GOP still supports him.
So I guess now he's trying to
compromise by finding someone
who's similar to McConnell.
Check out a few of the people
he's recommended.
First up, there's Hans Moleman
from "The Simpsons."
Next up, there's a smiley face
french fry.
[ Laughter ]
After that, he recommended
SpongeBob SquarePants'
grandmother.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, he recommended
Harry Potter after using
the "old" filter on FaceApp.
[ Cheers and applause ]
These are his recommendations.
-Wow.
-I don't know.
Hey, get this.
I heard that Beto O'Rourke
is preparing to run for
governor of Texas in 2022.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-They like this.
Yeah, so Beto has run
for senator, president,
and now governor.
If he loses this race,
the only thing left is
condo-board treasurer.
And finally,
two men in Australia
were arrested after they were
caught crossing the border
with $100,000
and a trunk full of KFC.
Say what you want, but that cash
will never not smell like
fried chicken.
♪♪
It's a very busy time
in New York City,
because the UN General Assembly
is officially under way.
Yeah. More than
100 foreign leaders are in town
to address the assembly,
while some are just here
to pick up a fiancée
for 90 days.
[ Laughter ]
I love when the UN General
Assembly is in session.
There's no greater joy
than watching
the president of Romania
walk into the M&M's Store.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, when else
are you going to spot
the president of Latvia holding
one of those restaurant buzzers
outside Bubba Gump Shrimp?
It's like, "Our table is ready.
Let's go."
Of course, the main focus of
this year's General Assembly
is fighting COVID.
Yep, nothing like holding
a superspreader event
to tackle a pandemic.
[ Laughter ]
There's actually some
real concern about
the General Assembly
turning into
a superspreader event,
because -- and this is real --
the UN is using the honor system
to check vaccinations.
-Ooh!
-What? The honor system?
I don't even trust
the honor system
when I give out candy
on Halloween.
It's like, "Please take one.
Oh, I know you're
going to take it.
Honey, they took the bowl.
They --
We don't even have a bowl
anymore."
Next, the UN
is going to be like,
"We believe further conflict
with the Taliban
will be avoided thanks to
our latest pinkie promise."
The first leader
to speak this morning
and address the pandemic
was none other than
the unvaccinated president
of Brazil, Jair Bolsonaro.
Yeah, that's like attending
a weight-loss conference
and hearing, "Please welcome our
first speaker, Colonel Sanders."
[ Laughter ]
After Bolsonaro spoke,
President Biden
then made his address
to the UN General Assembly.
It was the first time he spoke
to a room of full of
world leaders
confidently knowing
that they didn't have him
on mute.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden talked about
the pandemic, climate change,
and the withdrawal
from Afghanistan.
When he watched, former
president Trump was like,
"Pssh!
I got way more laughs than him.
Way more laughs."
People are talking about this.
Today, the U.S. Space Force
unveiled a uniform prototype
for its members.
Finally. Look at this.
Hmm.
Right now, every New York City
doorman is like,
"Are we in the Space Force?
What?
That's what we're wearing."
Can we see it again?
It looks like a line cook being
yelled at by Gordon Ramsay.
"Go to space with you, donkey!
Go to space!"
Seriously, by the time
you button up that jacket,
the space war is
going to be over, you know?
Yep, that is the new uniform,
until Jeff Bezos
buys the Space Force
and turns it into this.
Yeah, I love that.
He looks...
[ Applause ]
He looks like a mash-up
of Buzz Lightyear and Woody,
doesn't he?
Here's some good news.
Johnson & Johnson announced
its COVID booster shot is
94% effective when given two
months after the first dose.
People who got the J&J
were like,
"Yeah, that would have been nice
to know about three months ago."
Actually, everyone
who got J&J was like,
"We already got boosters.
They're called Moderna. Yeah."
[ Laughter ]
Well, this is great.
I saw that Google Meet --
Google Meet
is going to start automatically
adjusting webcam brightness
in users' browsers.
Yeah. And it's not the only
new feature they're adding.
Take a look at this.
-We here at Google Meet
are excited to announce
a brand-new feature to make your
experience better than ever.
That's right --
when you click "New Meeting,"
it will take you
directly to Zoom.
Google Meet --
at least we're not Skype.
-Yeah, isn't that amazing?
That's amazing.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
And, finally, a pair of
107-year-old sisters in Japan
just claimed the title of
world's oldest identical twins.
Yeah, and just to
creep people out,
they stand in the hallway of
their retirement home and say,
"Come play with us."
Today is officially
the first day of fall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course, some people are
sad that summer's over,
but good news -- thanks
to climate change, it's not.
That's right -- we're entering
that magical time of year where
we put on old jackets hoping
to find cash in the pockets.
You know? Some gum!
Let's get to some news.
After speaking here
in New York City
at the UN General Assembly,
President Biden
is back in Washington, and
today, he hosted world leaders
for a virtual summit
about COVID.
Yep, world leaders
traveled 4,000 miles to New York
just so they could Zoom from
their rooms at the Best Western.
Well, the summit lasted
more than four hours.
Four hours! By the end,
everyone was fatigued.
Everyone had body aches,
sore throats.
They were like, "Wait.
Do we have COVID?"
But the big takeaway from
the summit is that Biden
wants world leaders
to fully vaccinate 70%
of their population.
Then world leaders were like,
"Okay, you first."
[ Applause ]
"Deal. You..."
But this is good -- at the
summit, Biden announced that
the U.S. is buying an additional
500 million doses of
the Pfizer vaccine to share with
countries around the world.
Each country
will receive a basket with
an injectable arrangement,
which is interesting.
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
The White House says
they're gonna start
sending the doses in January.
Seriously? January?
Countries are like, "If I sign
up for Government Prime,
can I get that tomorrow?
January? Wow."
This is amazing.
Last night,
the winning ticket for
the $432-million
Mega Millions jackpot
was sold a block away from
our studio, at Pronto Pizza.
-Ooh!
-When asked what they'll do with
$432 million, the winner said,
"Hey, it's New York City.
I'm gonna move from my studio
to a one-bedroom.
Come on. Yeah."
Pronto Pizza!
And, finally, I saw
that Aston Martin is selling
a James Bond car for kids,
and it costs $123,000.
The kid who gets one
is going to be like,
"I'm a brat. Spoiled brat."
Today, President Biden hosted
a White House summit
with the leaders
of India, Australia, and Japan.
They talked about the world's
most pressing issues,
like the pandemic,
cybersecurity,
and Chris Pratt
being cast as Mario.
[ Laughter ]
The leaders also discussed
climate change
and "supply chain" issues.
Which means, in one meeting,
they covered
the future of the Earth
and Costco's
toilet-paper shortage.
[ Laughter ]
But the meeting
hit a rough patch
when the Australian
Prime Minister told Biden,
"Do you know that, where
I'm from, your presidency
is going down the drain
in the opposite direction?"
[ Laughter ]
Australia, India, and Japan.
Meanwhile,
the French Prime Minister
was across the street like...
[ Imitates puffing cigarette ]
"Those --"
[ Laughter ]
"Those betches."
Some more news --
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Imitates puffing cigarette ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"Those...
betches."
More news from Washington --
Republican Senator
Chuck Grassley,
who is 88 years old,
announced that he's running for
another six-year term in 2022.
Later, when he saw
the news coverage, he said,
"Wow. Good for Chuck Grassley."
[ Laughter ]
When a reporter asked if he's
too old, he said "Oh, please.
You sound like my great-great-
great-great-great-grandson."
[ Laughter ]
88? At that age,
you don't run for Senate,
you run for president.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Preach!
-[ Laughter ]
-"Good for Chuck Grassley."
[ Light laughter ]
"I'm Chuck Grassley."
This is fun.
I saw that Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle
are here in New York,
and they started off --
[ Cheers ]
They started off their trip
by meeting with
Governor Kathy Hochul.
At the meeting, Prince Harry
told the New York governor,
"I won't ask about your Andrew
if you don't ask about mine."
[ Laughter ]
Some COVID news.
The MTA said that they will
start issuing $50 fines
to riders not wearing masks.
Yep, it's $50
for not wearing a mask
and $100 for not muting your
phone's keyboard when you type.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitating keys clacking ]
Pbbbbb. Pbht!
[ Laughter ]
"Those..."
"...betches."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Never heard of that.
That's unbelievable.
Well, as I mentioned,
Nintendo just announced
that in the upcoming
"Super Mario Bros." movie,
Chris Pratt
will do the voice of Mario.
Yep. After the news came out,
some people said Mario
should be played
by an Italian actor.
To which Italians said,
"You know Mario
isn't a real person, right?"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Chris Pratt voicing Mario
is an interesting choice,
but it turns out
they considered
a lot of other people first,
and we actually got our hands
on the audition reel.
-Really?
-Yeah, take a look at this.
-It's a-me, Mario.
[ Laughter ]
And nothing's more important
to me than family.
Luigi is my family.
So is Toad.
Just 'cause Toad
doesn't look like me
doesn't mean we're not family.
[ Laughter ]
-What's up? I'm Mario.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my bad.
I mean, my name is Mario.
Wait, wait.
That's not right, either.
I meant to say,
"It's a-me, Mario."
[ Laughing ]
That was awesome!
-It's a-me, Mario.
And I'm a-looking for you.
I'm will a-find a-you,
and I will a-kill a-you.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah, it's me Mario.
[ Mumbling ]
Goomba and zoomba, roomba,
boom-boom to the koopa troopa.
-Oh, yeah, mamma mia.
[ Laughter ]
♪ I'm goin' to Nebraska,
and I'm drivin' a Jeep ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They didn't get it.
-They didn't get it?
-They didn't get the part.
-Aww.
-Some more entertainment news.
I read that "Tiger King 2"
is coming to Netflix
later this year.
Come on. More "Tiger King"?
I don't know whether to call it
a sequel or a variant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some business news --
Uber Eats just introduced
a new feature that lets
customers use emojis
to search for the food
they want.
It's the only time
you can text an eggplant
and actually wind up
with an eggplant.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
♪♪
Eggplant.
-[ Imitates cigarette puffing ]
[ Laughter ]
-"Those betches."
That's right.
You don't have to call,
you don't have to pick it up,
and now you don't even
have to type actual words.
Pretty soon, they're just
gonna show up at your house
and baby-bird the food
into your mouth.
[ Laughter ]
[ Spits ]
Finally, on Sunday night,
the Green Bay Packers
face off against
the San Francisco 49ers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
at the beginning of the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Superlatives ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Our first player is from
the 49ers, Jake Brendel.
He was voted Most Likely to be
Prince Harry's Cousin
Who Works at AutoZone.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, from the Packers,
is Robert Tonyan.
He was voted
Most Likely to say the Word
"Sick" in His Wedding Vows.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You look sick."
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Packers,
is quarterback Aaron Rodgers.
He was voted Most Likely to be
a Cool Youth Pastor who says,
"You know who
the real rock star is?"
and Then Point Up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next up,
from the Packers, is Dean Lowry.
He was voted Most Likely to say,
"Oh, this is my favorite movie,"
When Someone Points
a Laser Pointer at the Wall.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"My favorite character is dot."
[ Light laughter ]
Next, from the 49ers,
is Mitch Wishnowsky.
He was voted Most Likely
to Have Appeared in Every Season
of "The Bachelorette"
Without Anyone Noticing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I think I know that guy."
Next up, from the Packers,
is Billy Turner.
He was voted Most Likely to get
Whiplash from a Low Doorframe.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up, from the Packers,
is Isaiah McDuffie.
He was voted Most Likely
to be Drake's Wario.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, from the Packers,
is Mason Crosby.
He was voted Most Likely
to Play a Single Dad
in a Hallmark Christmas Movie
Called "Alone for the Holidays."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Table for one."
And, finally, from the 49ers,
we have George Kittle.
He was voted Most Likely
to Throw his Bong Water
Over the Coach After He Wins.